bonsoir à tous
un titre principal dans l'actualité ce
soir les terribles conséquences de la
tempête dans l'ouest de la france on
compte maintenant 59 morts et disparus
la plupart noyées dans leurs maisons en
vendée en charente maritime
les pompiers continuent à chercher les
rescapés les dégâts sont énormes et
milliers d'habitations sont encore sous
les eaux on sait maintenant que
plusieurs digues ont été submergés le
long des côtes
nicolas sarkozy s'est rendu sur les
lieux il a promis une aide immédiate de
3 millions d'euros
et on s'interroge déjà sur les règles
d'urbanisation images reportages
témoignages
nos équipes sont sur place nous serons
en direct avec nos envoyés spéciaux et
nos invités et nous essaierons de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé exactement
bienvenue donc dans cette édition
spéciale il y a un jour et demi la
tempête balayé la france et ce n'est
qu'aujourd'hui qu'on en mesure
pleinement l'impact premières images
regarder elles ont été tournées cet
après midi à bord d'un hélicoptère et on
réalise à quel point l'océan est entré
dans les terres les rues les routes les
jardins les résidences sont encore noyé
et dans plusieurs zones du littoral le
niveau de l'eau ne diminue pas en raison
d'une nouvelle grande marée le pompage
commence à peine
on reste encore dans une situation
d'urgence des plans aériens que nous a
envoyé tout à l'heure alain darrigrand
un département est particulièrement
meurtri c'est la vendée 33 morts au
moins et plusieurs disparus la plupart
dans deux villages côtiers la faute sur
mer et l'aiguillon sur mer
toute la journée les sauveteurs ont
poursuivi leurs recherches sur place
karine comazzi johann nertomb
c'est un lotissement fantôme où flottent
ce qu'il y a deux jours encore étaient
les objets du quotidien
jean marc raby ces pompiers plongeurs
dans le morbihan il est venu en renfort
pour vérifier maison après maison après
la première inspection faite hier il
nous explique pourquoi ces équipes
marquent le mur là elles refont une
deuxième reconnaissance pour s'assurer
et donc qu'il y ait vraiment personne et
leur ont permis d'être sur la vie de
militant et hésiter et lacroix qui a
personne dedans l'un des problèmes de
ces lotissements c'est que beaucoup de
maisons sont des résidences secondaires
mais les équipes ont leurs méthodes pour
savoir si elle était ou non occupés au
moment de la catastrophe
si tu rigoles un navigateur cela veut
dire que c'est une maison que d'être
secondaire
donc si frigo est vide c'est rien à
manger donc à personne ici pas sûr c'est
pas sûr mais ça nous donne déjà des
éléments c'est la politique on m a
glissé pendant un bébé le connaissions
tous les matins on voit des malfaçons
sur l'île et modestement nous
complaisons de plain-pied valorisation
sur l'ensemble ça non
le soleil décline et pourtant les
plongeurs se prépare à repartir sous
l'eau qu'est-ce qui est difficile si
l'on voit rien c'est trop cool de
montreux-jeune énormément de morceaux de
bois de toutes les voitures donc
ce pognon qui veut par tous cas les
secteurs et les profs ont rien de trouvé
tout est propre au moment où les
sauveteurs se réjouit c'est de n'avoir
trouvé aucun corps cet après midi notre
embarcation s'arrête une nouvelle
personne décédée a été retrouvé dans une
maison
les recherches vont se poursuivre
jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit
dans le même temps certains habitants
ont commencé à regagner leurs maisons
avec prudence car la marée est remontée
ce soir l'une de nos équipes étaient à
leurs côtés aujourd'hui reportage arnaud
content and i tree boire sur la route
qui mène à la pointe de l'aiguillon il y
à ces maisons ravagées abandonné en
pleine nuit par leurs habitants
et depuis quelques heures ce ballet
incessant de semis romain ces camions
acheminent dans l'urgence des tonnes de
blocs rocheux
il faut colmater au plus vite les
brèches de la digue
car avec les fortes marées de l'eau
pourrait s'engouffrer dans les terres
encore davantage les riverains assistent
aux travaux quelque peu angoissé
remonterait au hall a déjà et en plus
avec le vent et commencent à s'élever
ça fait peur un peu un peu plus loin cet
habitant préfère sauver ce qui lui reste
par crainte d'une nouvelle vague et on
arrive à quai déjà depuis hier
on s'attend à un jour un lot est parti
dans les terres à revenir et puis il a
marqué de morlaàs faut pas rêver et pour
ceux qui reviennent ici pour la première
fois depuis la tempête ont dû ce
sentiment d'avoir échappé au pire les
courants d'une force inouïe y ont tout
emporté dans leur sillage
alors là ça c'est une pièce frigorifique
servant aux métiers des cultes heures
qui était cédée à l'installation qu'il
ya là-bas scellé dans le béton est elle
arrivée jusqu'ici
dans ce restaurant situé en front de mer
certains murs n'ont pas résisté il y
avait un mur est de 40
tout est bondé
la véranda a été broyée séjour aussi les
vitres ont éclaté sous la pression de
l'eau les terres qu'ils étaient protégés
par la dic qui a cédé se sont
transformés en de véritables étant il
faudra sans doute plusieurs jours voire
plusieurs semaines pour que l'eau se
retire complètement et on revient
maintenant sur l'épreuve vécue par des
centaines ou des milliers de personnes
l'image qui vient à l'esprit pour
beaucoup c'est celle d'un raz-de-marée
l'eau est arrivée brusquement en pleine
nuit pendant leur sommeil
on l'a vu hélas parfois brisé les vitres
démoli les murs les rescapés sont partis
en catastrophe envoyés spéciaux
stéphanie perez arnaud jacques quelques
calmants pour tenter de reprendre le
dessus
christiane et andré à bayeux ont dû fuir
leurs maisons dévastés par les flots un
peu perdu ils ont trouvé refuge chez
leurs voisins à la lumière de la bougie
un bon café quelques paroles de
réconfort mais difficile d'oublier ces
longues heures d'angoissé arriver
partout ça explose et puis voilà on se
dit et ce que je viens cosmos est ce que
c'est vraiment les choses changent et
les chaussures d'une espèce de lawani
marie geneviève la voisine c'est qu'elle
a eu de la chance sa maison a été
épargnée
c'est pour cela qu'elle leur a ouvert sa
porte et leur maison est à refaire leur
maison bien sûr ce n'est pas la posséder
c'est pas la peine pour le moment la
maison de monsieur ravaille au est
inaccessible la détresse des sinistrés
chaque vendéen la ressent un peu dans sa
chair depuis ce matin au gymnase de
l'aiguillon transformés en centres
d'hébergement un ballet incessant celui
des habitants qui viennent apporter de
la nourriture des vêtements des
couvertures
on est plus heureux que les gens qui
sont inondés ici et donc on va essayer
de vider les armoires avec des choses
propres
on est ici parce que
notre père deux appels à venir là je ne
peux pas rester chez nous tranquilles en
entendant en regardant que les
informations tdc pas venir partager la
peine des gens passé le choc un peu de
chaleur enfin et certains sinistrés
retrouve des vêtements propres
en même temps que le sourire c'est
extraordinaire et à une solidarité
vraiment très très forte
et ça ça fait chaud au coeur ici tous
ceux qui viennent apporter leur aide
aujourd'hui le savent
passée l'émotion les sinistrés auront
besoin de soutien sur le long terme
c'est pour cela que l'élan de solidarité
est aussi vaste
bonsoir loïc de la mornais vous êtes en
direct à l'aiguillon sur mer est ce que
les pompiers est ce que les sauveteurs
ont pu accéder maintenant à toutes les
zones à toutes les maisons inondées
alors pas encore david et puis vous
savez une scène résume un petit peu
vient cette incertitude ce soir vous
l'avez vue nous étions tout l'après midi
avec karine comazzi et joanes mère ton
dans une embarcation des plongeurs de la
sécurité civile et l'après midi s'était
bien passé c'est à dire que nous
n'avions pas retrouver de nouvelles
victimes
et puis au tout dernier moment vous
l'avez vu notre embarcation a été parqué
sur le côté les pompiers venaient de
retrouver un nouveau corps et ne
souhaitait pas évidemment que nous le
film y ont alors la découverte de ce
nouveau corps le 27e ici à l'aiguillon
et quelque part je dit bien quelque part
est paradoxalement un signe encourageant
car on s'attendait à pire à bien pire il
redoutait presque vingt victimes danser
dans ces maisons inondées cela veut dire
par exemple que beaucoup de ses maisons
sont surtout des résidences secondaires
et qu'elle était inoccupée
d'un autre côté c'est un signe
inquiétant car 20 % des habitations sont
encore inexploré et vous l'avez vu pour
les plongeurs c'est une tâche très
difficile nous ont dit que cela
ressemblait quasiment à de l'exploration
des pav sous marine avec des meubles
entre deux eaux d'aider des débris dans
tous les sens où il sera très difficile
de retrouver de nouveaux corps donc il
faudra attendre demain
loïc il y a en ce moment même on le
disait une nouvelle et grande marée
quelles en sont les conséquences
alors cette grande marée bien nous
l'avons vécu très exactement à 17h20
17h30 il y avait un coefficient
exceptionnel de 115 ce qui est énorme
nous étions sur l'eau à ce moment là et
nous n'avons pas constaté d'augmentation
du niveau de l'eau ans
venge vous le voyez la pluie a repris
elle est incessante de quasiment toute
la journée et en fait le danger ça n'est
pas vraiment qu'il y ait de nouveaux
dégâts ou de nouvelles victimes c'est
surtout que eh bien cette ce coefficient
exceptionnel va retarder la décrue et va
faire en sorte que bien la
reconstruction va reprendre encore des
jours et des jours et que tout
simplement
eh bien les sinistrés ne sont pas au
bout du tunnel loïc de la mornais à
l'aiguillon sur mer
merci loïc pour toutes ces indications
on l'a dit si la mer s'est engouffrée
dans les terres c'est parce que les
digues et les remblais ont cédé on
reviendra un peu plus tard sur les
raisons de cette pression des eaux
mais d'abord pour bien comprendre il
faut avoir à l'esprit la configuration
du littoral pourquoi ces digues
quand ont-elles été construite avait-on
conscience des risques
explication florence mavic philippe
maire la vendée sous les eaux c'est un
peu comme si la nature reprenait de
façon cruelle ses droits car au 19e
siècle
cette région était un milieu aquatique
c'est l'homme qui a arraché les terres à
la mer les communes de l'aiguillon et de
la faute sont nés entre une presqu'île
et un estuaire
l'homme s'est longtemps cru protégé par
cette digue longue de cinq kilomètres
construite en 1845 une digue souvent
malmenés par les tempêtes et qui a fini
par se rompre en plusieurs endroits là
je reconnais plus parce que franchement
on en est temps qu'on n'avait pas et
puis la route existe plus pour ainsi
dire non on reconnaît plus rien du tout
elle faisait pourtant près de 8 mètres
de hauteur cette fameuse digue
on l'avait renforcée avec des pierres et
du ciment mais l'océan a brisé l'édifice
il a submergé les champs puis les
lotissements situés en dessous du niveau
de la mer un peu plus loin c'est un
remblai qui a cédé trop fragile pour
encaisser le choc
les rescapés ne sont pas surpris il faut
dire qu'il ya eu très peu de travaux de
fait que ça des zac complètement rappaz
- drilles depuis des années et c'est par
trop sur des rapports d'experts avait
pourtant pointé les faiblesses de ces
dit souvent très anciennes et les
dangers encourus par les habitants
parlant de risques de dégâts majeurs
cet été des travaux de consolidation
avait été décidée pour un montant de
trois millions et demi d'euros mais
l'état des digues n'est pas seule
responsable de la mort des riverains
la violence de cette tempête soulève
aussi la question des constructions en
zone inondable un plan de prévention des
risques impose désormais que l'on ne
bâtisse plus dans les zones classées
rouge et que l' on surélève les
nouvelles constructions dans les zones
en bleu sur cette carte
une réglementation qui faisait grincer
des dents certains maires il ya encore
deux ans qui me choque c'est qu'on a des
moyens d'une part je reste persuadé
qu'au niveau constructibilité on a
encore des possibilités ne ferai ce que
de monter peut-être éventuellement
d'autres parfums la volonté des élus de
développer leur station balnéaire
parfois contre vents et marées risque
désormais de se heurter au veto de
l'état est avec nous en direct
maintenant philippe de villiers bonsoir
vous êtes le président du conseil
général de vendée depuis des années et
vous dites ce soir qu'il faudra bien se
résoudre à changer les règles de
construction
bonsoir monsieur pujadas d'abord d'abord
enfin je pense que comme cela a été dit
dans le précédent reportage qu'il ya
deux solutions ou bien on endigue toute
la côte tout le littoral français ce
n'est pas raisonnable de toute façon la
mer sera toujours plus forte que l'homme
porte que les digues fusse-t-elle très
solide ou bien alors on éloigne les
constructions et pour répondre à votre
question je pense que c'est ce que j'ai
demandé ce matin au président de la
république qui m'a écouté avec attention
et qui a créé une mission
interministérielle pour aller dans ce
sens il faudra que à l'avenir on
interdise en france sur le littoral
tous les permis de construire pour des
maisons qui se trouverait au dessous du
niveau de la mer je sais que c'est
difficile pour les élus locaux
pour les communes mais je pense qu'il
faudra prendre cette décision maintenant
monsieur pujadas je vais vous dire ce
soir nous ne sommes pas dans le temps du
débat il faudra ouvrir ce débat il est
essentiel c'est le débat de la
prévention des risques
ce soir nous sommes dans le temps de la
compassion de la consolation de la
détresse partager et aussi des gestes
magnifique de solidarité qui viennent de
toute la france et que je voudrais
saluer mais ce soir nous sommes dans le
deuil que selon le mode antigone il faut
laisser les morts enterrer les morts on
a entendu pour revenir sur ce sujet tout
de même des permis de construire qu'il y
avait des alertes est-ce qu'on n'aurait
pas pu s que vous aussi n'auriez pas dû
alerter sur ce sujet auparavant la
sécurité du territoire et la sphère de
l'état
c'est une mission régalienne et les
permis de construire c'est la sphère de
la commune c'est pas la sphère du
département mais je vais pas me
défausser
les maires font leur travail le mieux
qu'ils le peuvent
quant à l'état il a été tout à fait
admirable en l'occurrence le préfet a
prévenu météo france a prévenu
mais on s'est trouvés monsieur pujadas
dans une situation séculaire qui était
la suivante une conjonction
métérologiques nous le savons maintenant
depuis quelques heures
grâce aux cartes mais togo on sait ce
qui s'est passé une conjonction
météorologiques avec trois éléments pas
deux éléments on est trois éléments un
vent fou près de deux cents à l'heure
sur un couloir qui est passé entre deux
communes la faute et l'aiguillon une
mère folle donc déchaînés et troisième
élément sur lequel je voudrais insister
c'est une dépression atmosphérique qui a
littéralement soulevé la mer ce qu'on
appelle ce que les marins appellent la
surcote qui a soulevé la mer et vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure à juste titre
de raz-de-marée
on s'est retrouvé devant un phénomène de
raz-de-marée est contre ce phénomène là
l'homme ne peut rien sinon la prudence
la précaution est probablement dans les
constructions à venir éloigner les
habitations merci philippe de villiers
d'avoir été avec nous on reviendra
effectivement dans un instant sur cette
conjonction très particulière que vous
décriviez
mais d'abord nous nous rendons dans un
autre département très touché il s'agit
de la charente-maritime à la rochelle
mais aussi plusieurs petites villes là
aussi des digues ont cédé à charron les
rescapés décrivent des scènes dantesques
reportage françois privat fabien tormos
à charron la du tiers des maisons reste
inhabitable pour longtemps avoir tout
perdu sauf l'essentiel la vie on peut
considérer sarah et son bébé comme des
miraculés
car l'événement est sorti je me suis
enfui par la fenêtre juste laisser
porter par le courant et qu'heureusement
y avait mes voisins juste là qu'ils ont
recueillies et on a fini la nuit on a
réussi à monter sur le temps la finale
sans toi écrivait dix mois voilà
rechercher activement depuis hier après
midi une grand mère et ses deux petits
enfants de 7 et 10 ans n'ont pas eu
cette chance
leurs corps ont finalement été retrouvés
dans ce lotissement
habituellement on aperçoit à peine la
mère du jardin de gérard dimanche matin
elle s'est invitée dans sa maison ça
sent trop chaude tous les bruits la mer
qui ronronne là dedans c'est
inimaginable c'est impressionnant ça
c'est grave et gravé pour toujours dans
la tête toute façon ce sont n'ira jamais
premier contact avec les compagnies
d'assurance et premier conseil vous faut
pas tout jeter ou liste est ce que l'on
jette ou prendre en photo ce que l'on
jette en même temps c'est difficile de
garder ses affaires abîmé comme ça à la
vue visiblement abasourdi par l'ampleur
des dégâts ségolène royal la présidente
de la région poitou charentes c'est la
désolation enfin
incroyable je pense la une les gens
besoin d'humains qualys idées sont dans
une solitude terrible en souffrance
les éleveurs cet après midi avec la
grande marée de coefficient 105 on
craignait une nouvelle montée des eaux
cela n'a pas été le cas le bilan en
charente maritime s'est en revanche
alourdi
on dénombre désormais 12 mois et on vous
retrouve sur place en direct françois
privat bonsoir vous avez passé la
journée sur place et tout le monde là
bas semble très marqué tout le monde est
très marquée mais tout le monde est très
digne on voit d'ailleurs des victimes
qui défilent actuellement derrière nous
la salle des fêtes pour récupérer des
bouteilles d'eau des vêtements secs et à
chaque fois on nous parle on nous dit
nous sommes des miraculés on a sauvé
l'essentiel notre vie alors on va
pouvoir continuer ici on va travailler
on va reconstruire on va racheter tout
ce qu'on a perdu et on va demeurer à
charron même si on aura des mauvais
souvenir pendant longtemps mais on
restera ici et puis on nous fait des
comparaisons avec la tempête de 99 la
grande tempête du siècle dernier
et que nous dit on est bien en 99 la mer
était entré dans les terres en 3 4
points
alors qu'ici c'est sur des dizaines de
kilomètres de côtes que la mer a pénétré
démarrer on n'avait pas vu cela depuis
trois générations mois françois privé à
charron merci françois un autre
territoire bien connu notamment des
touristes a été en partie dévasté
il s'agit de l'île de ré la balle aux se
retire peu à peu elle laisse derrière
elle de très gros dégâts sur place
antoine gaveau philippe dumas y peu à
peu l'océan se retire et découvrent
l'étendue des dégâts dans le petit
village de loix sur l'île de ré l'heure
est au bilan matériel une fois l'enfer
passé à la vente sur l'eau avec france
et les baies vitrées à la ses 40 points
que ça vous a fait qu'est-ce qu'on vous
avez vu ça le désarroi de la faiblesse
pour la faiblesse alors pour être plus
fort on est solidaires voisins
me tous viennent donner un coup de main
aux sinistrés si vous cachez nous mal de
choses pour moi c'était logique des
choses pour comprendre la cause de ces
inondations il faut prendre la mer et
s'apercevoir qu'en plusieurs endroits
les remparts de l'île n'ont pas tenu le
choc
le problème des innovations à l'île de
ré a été causée par seddik qui se sont
effondrés comme celle que vous voyez
derrière moi elle a lâché dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche par la pression
conjuguée du vent et de la marée
aujourd'hui la première priorité est de
reconstruire ses digues
alors les ouvriers s'activent ces jours
ci les marais continue d'être forte
tout le monde craint une nouvelle
avancée des eaux provisoire il va
falloir vraiment là la ferme ou faux
dans les jours à venir c'est important
de vraiment bien construire oui bien
l'art consolidé
pourrait dire que ça n'arrive plus
c'en a jamais de certitudes mais verra
bien car la tempête a aussi eu des
conséquences catastrophiques sur
l'économie de l'île ici on élevait des
poissons il ne reste plus rien de cette
ferme aquacole tout se noyer donc dans
ce monde complètement sous l'eau là on
en aurait pas met donc au dessus la tête
toute la production est perdue
pas sûr d'ailleurs que l'activité puisse
reprendre un jour c'est dramatique au
niveau aussi de là et toute l'énergie
qui avait été développé pour réaliser
ces choses qui sont balayés en très peu
de temps il faudra de toute façon
beaucoup plus pour tout reconstruire
la tempête est passée mais le ciel de
l'île de ré ne s'est pas éclairci pour
autant et puis la rochelle a subi de
plein fouet cette tempête la puissance
des vagues a balayé plusieurs gros
bateaux dans le port certains ont même
coup les très gros dommages aussi du
côté des ostréiculteurs fanny stand
l'air au pied des tours de la rochelle
ce matin le port de plaisance est
méconnaissable après le passage de la
tempête
une quinzaine de ponton se sont envolés
tordu par le vent et la mer soit 5 km de
passerelles détruite la moitié du port 1
re construit des bateaux sont accrochés
hors bord des quais d'autres sont
éventrés
sur les bateaux on a dix bateaux de
couler et à peu près de 200 bateaux qui
sont endommagés donc plus ou moins
gravement donc bateau par bateau ont
fait un pointage en face de l'île
d'oléron à fouras la mer a pulvérisé des
cabanes de pêcheurs le frigo de cette
maison a atterri dans le garage des
voisins vous voyez il reste plus rien en
monte sur les gravats un coup dur aussi
pour les ostréiculteurs charentais
la mère a submergé leurs cultures et la
saison s'annonce désastreuse 2011 2012
ça va être les années assez
catastrophique au niveau des ventes et
est donc ça en plus
bon ça va être ouais ça va être très
difficile de repartir
nicolas sarkozy leur a promis des aides
financières et la venue du ministre de
l'agriculture dans la semaine bonsoir
maxime bono vous êtes le maire de la
rochelle vous aussi vous avez connu la
tempête de 1999 est ce que vous diriez
vous aussi que la situation est encore
pire chez vous oui la situation est très
différente elle est parfois moins
spectaculaire que lorsque des des arbres
par centaines sont à sont abattus mais
la situation est bien pire et on s'en
aperçoit au fil des jours les fil des
heures les dégâts sont beaucoup plus
grave que ce qu'on avait pensé la
subversion été très destructrice je
pense au port de des minimes où
pratiquement 50% du port est à
reconstruire et c'est un miracle que
nous n'ayons pas connu en la matière de
pertes humaines
quand il a fallu à 4 heures du matin au
plus fort de la tempête évacuer les
personnes qui étaient restés à bord des
bateaux je pense aussi cette submersion
qui est qui est passé par dessus les
digues les digues ont tenu mais les la
mer est passé au dessus et tout un
quartier le quartier de la ville en bois
a vu une zone artisanale de dédié
essentiellement à l'industrie nautique
une industrie qui avait été déjà
durement frappées par la crise être
totalement totalement jeunes aux ir
anéantie parce que messi de travail
n'existe plus 7
et puis les populations de là dans la
vieille ville la mer est entré alors la
vieille ville est plus protégé elle a
été bâtie un peu différemment
mais c'est un traumatisme terrible pour
l'ensemble des roches les quais les
formes aujourd'hui avec le temps qui
passe
quelle est pour vous la première urgence
la première urgence maintenant que nous
avons pu héberger tous ceux qui se
trouvaient dans la difficulté que nous
avons pu les réconforter que nous
trouvons des solutions individuelles
la première urgence pour nous c'est de
rebâtir les outils de travail
certains en ont plus d'outils de travail
je pense ostréiculteurs je pense aux
industriels du nautisme je pense aux
restaurateurs qui ont vu leurs salles de
restaurants de bars etc
totalement détruite donc permettre de de
retrouver les d'avoir rapidement accès à
des capitaux ils leur permettent
d'investir de renouveler leur outil de
travail et de continuer tout simplement
avec leurs salariés à exercer leurs
activités et de remettre l'économie
debout merci maxime bono d'avoir été
avec notre économie de bouts et puis
bien sûr dans un deuxième temps pour
nous de repenser la ville de réagir
différemment
on va maintenant essayer de comprendre
précisément ce qui s'est passé météo
france avait certes très bien anticipé
la violence de la tempête mais personne
n'imaginait un tel déferlement des eaux
juste avant cette explication je vous
propose de revivre le film des
événements heure par heure chronologie
d'une tempête avec olivier carol
elle est arrivée à leur dit en pleine
nuit une tempête particulièrement
violente qui va trouver un allié en
atteignant la france
l'océan atlantique et ses grandes marées
7 à 5 dans ma bulle aux yachts
j y tiens est né vendredi dernier sous
les tropiques les satellites la voie à
se diriger vers l'espagne et le portugal
quand ces images sont prises elle n'a
même pas 24 heures d'existence ses vents
atteignent 147 km heure par endroits en
france 68 départements les deux tiers du
pays se retrouve en état d' alerte
orange nous arrimer tout vous fermez
tout et vous vous mettez à la moyenne
mais dans l'après midi du samedi les
prévisions s'aggrave passant rouge
bâtiment ainsi que l'avant dès l'alerté
rouge n'a été déclenchée qu'une fois à
ces dix dernières années
xynthia va frapper très fort c'est déjà
à ce moment là une certitude
voilà ça colle à la panique la sur le
port en vendée une digue a cédé sur la
petite commune de l'aiguillon sur mer
l'eau s'engouffre dans les rues les
maisons les habitants sont surpris dans
leur sommeil certains doivent la vie aux
secouristes
d'autres un bon réflexe on est sorti par
la fenêtre et on a nagé jusqu'à chez les
voisins hélas tous les meubles flotex
vont très vite et très très vite très
très très très vite
en l'espace de quoi un quart d'heure
c'était incroyable au matin la mère est
partout sur des kilomètres la cote a
disparu il reste des îlots que les
services de secours mettront parfois
plusieurs heures à atteindre
dans ce camping de charente maritime
l'aide ne peut venir que du ciel
ce lotissement lui était occupé par de
nombreuses personnes âgées que les
sinistrés eux mêmes vient de se courir
page 2 sort monsieur connaître hors de
londres en show jean tient elle a encore
des forces elle traverse le pays qu'à
pau nord-est
elle sème le chaos depuis les montagnes
pyrénéennes
j'ai vu depuis un couloir les pylônes
s'effondrer est tombés sur les maisons
j'ai vu là la cabane du ski seller soit
totalement il reste plus rien jusqu'aux
côtes bretonnes qui se voyait mieux
protégés que ceux la mer les huit heures
j'ai jamais vu ça
j y tiens et la tempête la plus
meurtrière depuis celle de 1999
et malgré les alertes la france a été
une fois encore prise de court alors
pourquoi de tels dégâts pourquoi une
telle montée des eaux pour bien
comprendre alban nicosie nous a rejoint
bonsoir alban en fait il y a eu combien
raison de plusieurs phénomènes
l'addition de quatre phénomènes avant
tout démarré que l'on annonçait très
forte des marais de pleine lune des
marées d'équinoxe autant dire que l'eau
va rentrer profondément dans les terres
deuxièmement il ya cette tempête que
l'on voit arriver d'espagne une tempête
très creuse concrètement la masse d'air
à l'intérieur et très légère elle ne
joue pas son rôle de couverte elle
n'empêche pas l'eau de monter
troisièmement il y a ces pluies n'est
plus très importante et très brutal
l'eau de ruissellement ne parvient pas à
s'évacuer
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet
d'entonnoir enfin le vent plaque la mer
contre le rivage les ouvrages de défense
sont engloutis derrière il ya les
populations qui sont sans défense
est ce qu'il ya des précédents deux
phénomènes de ce genre alors c'est un
phénomène rare exceptionnel mais on se
souvient de deux épisodes le premier set
aux pays-bas en 1953 1850 personnes
avaient trouvé la mort dans des
inondations à ses proches dû à une
tempête très forte également à démarrer
le gouvernement néerlandais avait décidé
de revoir totalement sa politique en
matière de 10 deuxièmement il y
évidemment katrina en 2005
on se souvient que l'eau avait mis un
temps infini plusieurs semaines a quitté
les rivages de la louisiane voilà
pourquoi les opérations de pompage
seront importantes
voilà pourquoi elles vont durer
longtemps merci hell bourg nicosie et
dès aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy s'est
rendu sur place
il annonce une aide de première urgence
il évoque aussi une mission d'inspection
sur
règle des permis de construire romain
mais si olivier martinez 20 minutes
d'hélicoptère pour constater l'étendue
de la catastrophe
silencieux le visage grave
nicolas sarkozy découvre ses morceaux de
terre qui ont disparu sous la mer
quelques minutes plus tard à l'aiguillon
sur mer commune sinistrée
le président de la république rencontre
les rescapés ceux qui ont échappé à la
noyade la fenêtre j'ai vu la veille à
l'eau jusqu'à la hauteur de la fenêtre
et puis en fin de compte ce qui m'a
sauvé c'est que j'avais nagé
on est des semaines à l'abri et un coach
est venu ici j'étais tout nu
notre quartier notre cas des morts c'est
puissiez récupérer vos maisons tout est
possible et le chef de l'état n'oublie
pas de saluer le travail des sauveteurs
on avait des bons jusqu'au cou on arrive
à les faire sortir félicitations nicolas
sarkozy promet une enquête sous dix
jours pour comprendre les raisons de
cette catastrophe et annonce des mesures
immédiates pour déclencher de possibles
d'assurance il faut l'arrêté de
catastrophe naturelle
demain les signes et demain enfin même
aujourd'hui un intermédiaire quelqu'un
qui ne s'occupera que de ça sera aux
côtés pour discuter de façon collective
perçu la détresse également chez les
ostréiculteurs de charente maritime les
parcs à huîtres sont dévastés moi j'ai
deux tracteurs un bateau tout et pour un
mètre cinquante d'eau perdus nicolas
sarkozy annonce un plan spécial pour les
ostréiculteurs dans l'immédiat 3
millions d'euros sont débloqués pour
soutenir les victimes de la tempête
et puis notez que la campagne des
régionales s'en trouve affectée en pays
de loire par exemple l'ump le parti
socialiste ont décidé d'un commun accord
de suspendre leur implication pendant 48
heures dans cette campagne et il n'y a
pas que la côte atlantique qui a subi
cette tempête le vent a soufflé très
fort dans la région de toulouse et dans
les pyrénées exemple la situation de
superbagnères
elle a décidé de fermer ses portes trop
de dégâts la saison est terminée
hélène vergne david bres sur place l aie
a plus rien regarder de la toiture du
restaurant de montagne il ne reste que
la charpente tout le reste tall velux et
en vo lee la cuisine sera inutilisable
pour toute la saison
normalement la station est fermée le 5
avril donc voila moi
un mois et demi d'exploitation de quoi
en faire bon là c'est impossible
vite allez les gars quand même des
pointes à 210 km heure dans la station
de ski de superbagnères des toitures ont
été arrachées
les rafales de vent ont même projeté des
voitures les unes contre les autres les
équipements de ski télésiège et canons à
neige ont également souffert quand on a
à peu près 20% de garde-corps sur le
télésiège qui ont été abîmés tordu ou
cassés mais dès demain 11 pistes au lieu
de quatre seront accessibles aux skieurs
à luchon revanche il faudra du temps
pour effacer toutes traces de la tempête
une centaine d'arbres à terre dont
certains remarquable beaucoup d'arbres
de recouper et 6 mai l'araucaria là qui
est par terre
soit une première estimation de 2
millions d'euros de dégâts pour la
commune de luchon et sa station de ski
et c'est toute la france qui a été
balayé ce matin encore on compte est un
million de foyers privés d'électricité
il en restait quelque 170 milles en fin
d'après-midi la région d'orléans a été
l'une des plus touchées valérie le rouge
mathias barrois ici commence et c'est un
plan de vol peu ordinaire il s'agit du
réseau électrique du loiret fortement
touchée il doit être ausculté mètre par
mètre pour localiser les pannes
hélicoptère va être d'un grand secours
parce que il lui faut à peu près trois
quarts d'heure pour faire l'ensemble du
secteur alors qu'à pied il nous faudrait
plus d'une demi journée
cet hélicoptère ont été affrétés par
erdf seul moyen de franchir les haies
les forêts les propriétés privées sans
perdre de temps et pour trouver ce qui a
provoqué les ruptures de câbles
d'éléments extérieurs
bien cachée au milieu du bois ici c'est
un sapin qui s'est couché sur une ligne
moyenne tension plongeant 10000 voisins
dans le noir l'information est aussitôt
donnée aux équipes sur le terrain
là on a les trois phases à terre et
quatre confort l'arraché pour est on a
déjà des coupes et les troncs réparer
les poteaux et tirer de nouveaux câbles
c'est une course contre la montre pour
les électriciens y en aura remis ce soir
puis 80% des clients et je pense que
demain plus de 95% des clients devraient
être rétablis en électricité d'un soir
mais toutes les régions ne retrouveront
pas le courant aussi vite que le loiret
notamment celles qui ont encore ce soir
les pieds dans l'eau une image encore
cette tempête venue du portugal et
l'espagne poursuit sa route vers l'est
images ici de l'allemagne durement
touché également avec cinq victimes
au total ces dernières 24 heures et puis
elle vous êtes nombreux à proposer votre
aide depuis hier et bien sachez que
france télévisions s'associe à la
fondation de france à cet effet vous
pouvez si vous le souhaitez envoyer vos
dons boîtes postales 22 75008 paris ou
par internet sur le site fondation de
france point org
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire ce soir sur
cette tempête dernier bilan donc 59
morts ou disparus bilan toujours
provisoire
dans le reste de l'actualité une autre
catastrophe au chili à ce jour le
tremblement de terre a fait 720 morts le
chili qui s'est résolu aujourd'hui à
demander une aide internationale car des
milliers de personnes attendent toujours
les secours
gérard griesbeck cette fois c'est un
pillage à grande échelle dans un
supermarché de santiago tout doit
disparaître
la police semble impuissante face à un
tel flot les sacs de farine s'envoler en
priorité j'ai besoin de nourriture parce
que je n'ai presque rien à manger depuis
plusieurs jours
on a besoin de farine
la police tente de contenir la foule
mais rien n'y fait ici le pillage prend
des allures daide humanitaire pour tout
un quartier renforts militaires
couvre-feu la nuit dans les grandes
villes une première depuis la dictature
de pinochet
l'état cherche à rétablir l'ordre le
bilan du séisme s'est encore alourdi
plus de 700 morts près de deux millions
de chiliens ont été touchés certaines
villes ont disparu sous les flots comme
ici à talca à l'étranger en corps et en
bref la reprise du procès de radovan
karadzic devant le tribunal pénal
international de la haye l'ancien chef
politique des serbes de bosnie juger je
vous le rappelle d'angelos il a présenté
sa défense pendant près de cinq heures
défense qu'il assure seul
il a clamé sans surprise son innocence
la vieille amitié franco russe se porte
bien le président dmitri medvedev est
arrivé aujourd'hui à paris pour une
visite de trois jours
signature d'un accord sur le gaz et
nouveau partenariat stratégique annoncé
pour la première fois paris va vendre
quatre navires de guerre à moscou des
navires de type mistral
l'actualité judiciaire avec une énigme
de retour devant les assises le procès
en appel de jacques viguier a commencé à
albi ce professeur de droit de 52 ans
bien connu est soupçonné vous le savez
d'avoir tué sa femme disparue il ya dix
ans et dont on n'a jamais retrouvé le
corps
il avait été acquitté en première
instance dominique verdeilhan mathias
seconde l'alluré déterminé encadré de
ces trois nouveaux avocats jacques
viguier affronte ce second procès avec
détermination
pas un mot à la presse or le cellulaire
mais face aux jurés il se livre sans
retenue je n'ai pas été un mari parfait
mais j'ai été choqué on m'a traitée de
notables de pervers de don juan il y a
dix ans presque jour pour jour le 27
février 2000 suzanne viguier
raccompagner chez elle par son amant
on la reverra plus les soupçons se
portent sur le mari pourquoi at il fait
disparaître le matelas sur lequel son
épouse dormait
quoi avoir attendu trois jours pour
signaler sa disparition
les trois enfants de l'accusé sont
présents pour leur faire n'a pas tué
leur mère
mais la tonalité est tout autre du côté
des soeurs de la victime
je crois à 300% capable même plus sympa
ça c'est bon signe
c'est un nouvel équipement
je pense pas
ce serait probable east
depuis dix ans jacques viguier se dit
innocent moi je suis innocente c'est
depuis le début mais ma femme a disparu
et on ne l'a pas retrouvée qu'est ce
qu'elle est devenue
c'est une question qui nous taraude il
nous rêvent dans l'esprit en paix que
quand on en a répondu à cette question
qu'est-il arrivé à susi
le professeur de droit jacques viguier
n'ignore pas que ce second procès est à
hauts risques selon les statistiques du
ministère de la justice s'il acquittait
sur dix sont finalement condamné lors de
leur procès en appel
le rideau est tombé hier sur les jeux
olympiques à vancouver cérémonie de
clôture grandiose encore une marquée par
la joie des canadiens ils ont remporté
le titre qui leur tenait le plus à coeur
grégory naboulet virginie travers lors
d'une dernière nuit colorée
le canada a fermé les yeux sur 17 jours
de jeu le sentiment du devoir olympique
accomplie
la liesse dans les tribunes témoignent
de la double réussite canadienne dans
ces jo réussite festive mais surtout
sportive
hier soir lors de la finale de hockey
sur glace signer cosby a propulsé les
rouges dans l'histoire ce but en or
marqué en prolongation d'une finale
d'anthologie contre les états unis
permet au canada de remporter le 14e
titre olympique de ces jeux un nouveau
record c'est alors un pays tout entier
qui descendent dans la rue
les canadiens sont fiers de leur équipe
de hockey et de l'image qu'ils ont
offerte au monde
pendant ces jeux une dernière fois la
flamme a illuminé vancouver le temps que
les athlètes des 82 délégations fassent
leurs adieux au 21e jeux d'hiver au beau
milieu de cette troupe olympique les
français repartent avec 11 médailles
dont deux en or et des souvenirs plein
la tête
quand on finit des jeux comme ça on a
envie d'une seule chose c'est de
recommencer c'est le genre de
compétition qu'on voudrait éternelle et
l'action devant tout de suite ouais
ouais
dans quatre ans j'aimerais bien dans
quatre ans justement les jeux prendront
la direction de sotchi
le flambeau est passé au russe désormais
de relever un défi celui de faire aussi
bien que les canadiens et en attendant
notez que les paralympiques commenceront
le 12 mars prochain pour dix jours à
vancouver
beaucoup d'épreuves seront d'ailleurs
diffusée sur france télévisions une
image de football le classique de ligue
1 psg om a tourné à la déroute pour le
paris saint-germain défaite 3 0 hier au
parc des princes but de ben arfa lucho
et cheyrou marseille qui prend la
quatrième place au classement encontre
marquée par ailleurs par des incidents
les supporters de l'om avait pourtant
boycotter la rencontre mais ceux du psg
se sont affrontés entre eux un homme de
38 ans était grièvement blessée image
signée sébastien laffargue avant de
refermer ce journal je vous en rappelle
bien sûr la principale information
le dernier bilan de la tempête s'est
nettement alourdie ces dernières heures
on compte maintenant 59 morts et
disparus la plupart noyées dans leurs
maisons principalement dans les
départements de vendée et de
charente-maritime
les pompiers continuaient aujourd'hui à
chercher les rescapés les dégâts sont
énormes
des milliers d'habitations sont encore
sous les eaux plusieurs digues ont été
submergés le long des côtes et on
s'interroge déjà sur les règles
d'urbanisme
nicolas sarkozy s'est rendu sur les
lieux il a promis une aide immédiate de
3 millions d'euros à l'instant on
apprend que l'arrêté de catastrophe
naturelle a déjà été signé c'est la fin
de cette édition spéciale merci à tous
tout de suite la météo tania young qui
nous annonce le retour du soleil
20h35 fbi portés disparus 22h05 mots
croisés il quelle vie reviendra sur
cette tempête xynthia avant un grand
débat sur les régionales à demain merci
l'info en continu